are you
the type of uh manager who will
work with an artist
based strictly on how good the music is
and
maybe there's no numbers behind 100 i'm
not a number chaser sometimes you got to
go with your feelings it's like baseball
like everything's now is like
not by the coach can't really call is
all analytic basically analytic base
yeah money ball [ __ ] yeah
that's not how you def you feel a star
like you get that
quality when you see them when you meet
them you know i'm saying watching them
interact with people watching them
perform so that can't be just dictated
by numbers you know i'm saying that's a
feeling that that's i mean that's real i
think that you want to do a mix you want
to be a hybrid you you definitely don't
want to start i know me at this point
i'm too busy to start with artists who
are at zero
so if you're at a four or five i can
help but if you got 12
instagram followers yeah it's like i i i
can't do that and there's other managers
at this point that can and are willing
to do have you done that where like
someone will come to you and you're like
yo i see the potential but i can't take
this on right now every day let me lob
this to somebody